foreign
[Music]
Tomatoes is wrong I am Mark Ellis joined
as always by my co-host Jaclyn Coley we
got a great guest in studio today and we
are in Los Angeles it doesn't feel like
Los Angeles does not it's quite
depressing as what did you say I moved
to LA not to Seattle yeah I feel like I
should get like a like a bump off my
rent or something just because this is
not why I moved to California it's Doom
and Gloom every morning I wake up now
this is different from me because this
is the we're filming this the week that
everyone comes back and like if you saw
my Instagram story in that time I
definitely talked about it's like back
to life back to reality it just like
whips you up inside the face but when
it's rainy like this I go to sleep with
this rain this is how I actually go to
bed every night like because I'm a
damaged individual I have to listen to
rain sounds to make it to where you know
the monsters don't keep me awake I like
the little Rolling Thunder that I get on
my sound machine but now I'm doing ocean
waves so wait a minute so right now with
this rain that we have like as is just
normal which is a rarity in California I
just want to sleep all day so everyone's
like giddy up like I've lost all
ambition like you're like do you want to
rule the world no no I just want to take
a nap I just want to sleep I want to eat
soup and uh to be honest it's why we're
doing this episode today I want to watch
horror movies and we have a great horror
movie that we're going to be talking
about it's a little controversial on the
Tomato Meter which is again why we love
doing this show we're talking about
Bride of Chucky and we have a very
special guest with us and it's the one
the only one third of the world girls in
their empire she's an incredible host
she's an incredible producer behind the
scenes it's dorina Ariana hello darina
hola hola how's everybody doing happy to
be here in the flesh it's the first time
I've seen you well not the first time
I've seen you in person we've seen each
other like movie premieres and stuff but
this is like the first time it's like
with a microphone as you were meant to
be yeah I just love seeing in your
element like in person same because it's
not the same when you go to the parties
in the premieres everybody's you know
like I'm so glad that the three of us
actually enjoy sitting in our couches
and watching movies instead of going to
those things fast way more we do see
each other there but it's like when we
see each other it's like we don't want
to be here nobody really like we want to
be here because we want to be here but
we don't want to be out of our house
like anything outside of the house no
matter how cool it is it has to be this
cool basically to make either one of us
want to put on pants I think that's why
we're all Lucky is because we work in
movies somewhat in this industry and so
one of the perks of that is like yeah
you go to like some parties and stuff
and you get to go to a Premiere maybe
get a free drink afterwards but you also
have a two to two and a half hour window
where all the lights are going down yes
and you're not supposed to talk to
anybody else because there's a movie
playing love that and there's a there's
a movie coming out this weekend called
Megan that I think kind of relates to
the film we're talking about today which
once again is Bride of Chucky 47 rotten
on both the tomato and the audience
score metric so a rare tie there and
this is obviously in the lineage of
Child's Play where you had 1988 blessing
us with everyone's favorite little
murderous puppet Chucky I guess he's not
a puppet he's a he's like a my buddy
he's a my buddy but I mean he my how
dare you he's a marionette he's a
marionette because he does speak like
the idea that it can be a doll that has
any kind of but he's got no strings to
hold him down he doesn't have any
strings hold him down but I mean he
still speaks like what do you call a
talking doll an icon Chucky is an icon I
don't know what you guys are talking
about calling him up seriously let's
clip that out that was that was that was
so so why is Chucky such an icon because
there's nobody like him there's who else
does I mean look when the commercials
for my buddy came out in the 80s and I
was a kid they freaked me out so much
I'm like why would I want to hang out
with that little guy I didn't I didn't
like the song I just did it'd creep me
out and then I see Chucky for the first
time child's play in the 80s and I'm
like this is exactly what I imagine my
buddy being right so this this I've
always also been freaked out by dolls so
Chucky actually represents the truth
about how creepy dolls are see I have
not so like I was a Barbie girl like
with the Dream House with everything
longer than people re like I I tell this
story now but I had I played Barbies
until I was like 13 14. like there were
girls that were like oh I just want to
like get behind the bleachers here
that's yeah that's like freshman year
high school stuff yeah yeah wow yeah I
still so because I own that I did own it
you know why because I lived in a Land
of Make-Believe and Mike like I had
entire soap opera level Seasons with
these people you can't just let that go
because all of a sudden you're like you
know body gets weird this was investment
okay I feel like playing with Barbies in
high school is actually the Barbies
themselves have much more like the the
landscape so what Barbies can get into
now that you're in high school and
you're having all these feelings in
yourself it leads to a lot of adventures
with Barbie and this Skipper probably
stays home all of this was just reasons
for me to like be a burgeoning writer
like the kit like ran away from home
like there was a whole issue with Ken
not wanting to get a job there was like
a hole like this is like soap up I was
basically putting Days of Our Lives
story lines on this and now I remember
at 14 I finally got rid of my Barbie
dream house and like they had like rooms
and like I was like giving them all
story lines be like well last week this
is what happened
Jacqueline's bedroom last week well you
know it's interesting that you're you're
putting your Barbies into relationships
like my sister used to have them date GI
Joe and it was I used to burn them match
up okay some people would go in the
woods and put stuff on fire I did my
share of that as well but Bride of
Chucky gives us this sort of romantic
relationship that we get with Chucky's
bride who is voiced by the wonderful
Jennifer Tilly so there's a lot to get
to with this movie we're gonna
disseminate all this stuff Chucky has
been a favorite here at Rotten Tomatoes
because he's always the subject of some
video we're doing I had the pleasure of
doing a versus episode where it was
Chucky versus leprechaun and I think
Annabelle's been in the mix there too so
we kind of love just these like tiny
little things that you should love or
that should Inspire children like a doll
or like a fun leprechaun that you see on
the Lucky Charms box and they end up
being great fodder for horror movies so
we're going to be talking about some
other Child's Play stuff focusing on
Bride of Chucky which I saw for the
first time last night for the first time
first time Pop That Old Cherry and uh
very excited about doing so Jacqueline
if you would please give us just a
little tiny synopsis as to what Bride of
Chucky is about yes I will give you the
synopsis of bribe chunky I also want to
add I actually last saw this movie when
Mark did the video for Chucky versus
leprechaun it literally was so great it
had me like going back to watch it and
like yes okay so Bride of Chucky in case
the title doesn't give it away if Chucky
is our Frankenstein sign this is the
part where we assemble his bride she
this is Tiffany Valentine this is a
former lover of the actual guy who is in
sort of embodied into the Chucky doll
she dies and we of course have to go
into our Frankenstein type thing the
best part about this one is it's voice
by Jennifer Tilly and just picture her
sort of like doll like features being
portrayed into this and you get a good
idea of it of course through you know
Chucky going through all of the things
he's trying to do to make her come alive
sometimes they are working sometimes
they're not eventually he does get her
to come alive and then surprise surprise
she doesn't want to have anything to do
with him at first just as you would
expect but they sort of team up go
through more adventures and in the end
we do get our eventual going down the
aisle Bride of Chucky and this best part
of this one also is that the Chucky is
also reanimated because this is also the
Chucky where we get to see him with the
very scarred awful face I think I hit
the major points on this yeah his face
kind of looks like a baseball he looks
like a baseball yes and and again voiced
by Brad Dora if again a fine love in a
hopeless place horror comedy rom-com I
will give it to you this is not a horror
movie kids this is a love story for the
ages very true beautifully done it is it
is and we have all the horror movies
from uh from Bloom house which is
putting out Megan are that's also one of
the editorials right now on
rottentomatoes.com so y'all can go check
that out
um dorina the question here is simple
and it's also the name of the show is
Rotten Tomatoes wrong about Bride of
Chucky which is 47
rotten I love this company and I love
the employees that work for it but it's
just wrong so many times Mark so wrong I
mean it's lower than rise of Skywalker
which is interested me this and I'm not
or you you responded to a tweet and you
brought Starbucks what is Star Wars rise
of skyrocker there were 40 I think it's
in the 50 something really yeah so it's
actually one of the few rotten ones
should be fresh but yeah the prequels
are mostly fresh
[Music]
rise of Skywalker
Schrader he loves all of it no he does
it well specifically Star Wars
there's some Star Wars that I think
could be rotten but ryzer Skywalker
ain't it about to say I was like no no
no no no no he that he he falls in the
JJ Camp the only part that was not
around was bubble freak but anyways look
the opening sequence of this movie is
one of the most fun and horror iconic
moments I think in any any horror
franchise the fact that Jennifer Tilly
we get to watch her rebuild Chucky yes
to like uh Rob Zombie's Living Dead Girl
yes right and uh and basically like
she's re I think this is the scene where
she's actually reading Voodoo for
dummies yes so it's just such a great
scene uh and I think that's why
everybody has that song on their
Halloween playlist
um yeah I was so happy to see Rob Zombie
being on the soundtrack get a little bit
of white zombie in there too uh before
we get into the movie talk Jaclyn you
are on the same Train's arena is Rotten
Tomatoes wrong about pride of Chucky
it's a little wrong it's a little wrong
okay but come on this is another one of
those where you have a movie where I
always have a movie that I like to
compare other movies to and when it
comes to the rotten around in the
40-year Mark I always bring this up
anyone listening to this podcast knows
this Constantine is my Watermark if that
movie could not get a fair Shake I
cannot give it to your bloody romcom and
I forgot that that's right the best part
about this story is they both literally
bring each other to life first Jennifer
Tilly bringing Chucky to life reanimated
stitching him up but then also him
bringing her to life as she has
basically you know doomed herself due to
her bringing him to life it's this whole
idea of them coming together yes and we
also get a young Catherine Heigl in this
place
not as young as Wish Upon a Star which
is my favorite Katherine Heigl
performance if you don't know that was a
Disney movie from back in the day where
she does a body swap with whatever yeah
I meant to mention this about Bride of
Chucky it is uh corpse you know like a
Bride of Frankenstein meets Bonnie and
Clyde meets um I you know every breakup
the breakup up with uh Jennifer Aniston
and Vince Vaughn and then it comes
together with this like amazing Jennifer
Lopez Hugh Grant style like I love you
in spite of yourself welcome like this
movie has it all and then it's bloody
and terrifying all the way through so a
little bit of Natural Born Killers
that I'm talking about too but no
definitely more Natural Born Killers
there's a much after like Bonnie and
Clyde were saintly compared to what
these two go on their Rampage but what I
was just gonna say is um it's still not
gonna be that great so I could see maybe
getting it to 50. okay but it's not
fresh but it's not fresh and so I really
just think it should stay where it is
because it's already higher than
Constantine that was my point now do you
think it should be any of the Chucky
movies would be fresh
well the first one is isn't it or no it
is what it is yeah it should be because
that's that's the best one yes the first
one is and I do believe that that one
earns its place let's just think I've
seen Bride of Chucky I've seen Child's
Play one and two I have not seen Seed of
Chucky and I think I'm poor for it
uh and I've definitely not seen Child's
Play I want to see Seed of Chucky now
after seeing this again for the first
time so I'm gonna say Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong about Bride of Chucky I think this
is a fresh movie mainly because of the
comedic elements here that they lean
into that they know it's campy they know
what they're getting after and it's sort
of reinvigorating a franchise and really
a genre that I think desperately needed
it and there it's no accident that
there's a very overt nod to Bride of
Frankenstein which I will say by the way
the 1935 classic probably better than
the original Frankenstein 98 certified
fresh in the Tomato Meter so I'm not
saying pride of Chunky's that good but I
think it does deserve to be fresh
completely agree Mark I'm so glad
especially because you just watched it
for the first time but what you just
said it's like screamed before it yeah
obviously they took inspiration from
what uh Wes Craven and Kevin Williamson
did because it's complete it's obviously
very self-aware that it's a parenting
scene it's a different type of scene but
it's still your opening heroine dying
scene it's the same type of like Drew
Barrymore type scene you know what I
mean yeah it's a great way to to get you
into the the movie and a great way to
get you to this podcast is our buddy Tim
Ryan oh yes sir expert review curation
manager here I know it's in we're
excited we want to jump into Bride of
Chucky I know we really do we give two
minutes with Tim it's run he's our
review creation guy he compiles all the
reviews looks at all the stuff and he's
going to tell us what the critics were
saying at the time of Bride of Chucky's
release on the heels of Kevin
Williamson's scream Tim take it away
humans with Tim the most venerable
horror movie franchises usually start
out the same way there's a terrifying
antagonist who is the embodiment of a
primal human fear it could be Jason
Voorhees as a stand-in for our fear of
the woods it could be Freddy Krueger who
we covered in a previous episode as the
manifestation of our subconscious or it
could be Chucky our malevolent entity in
a seemingly innocent package once said
Boogeyman catches on with the public
however there's a decent chance that
they shift from antagonist to
protagonist and in other words more
campiness and catchphrases less
personification of dread that's not
necessarily a bad thing at least for
fans of the character but it's also not
necessarily a recipe for critical
success and though some critics found
Bride of Chucky to have some decent
scares and a satirical self-awareness
about its status as yet another entry in
a horror franchise others felt it wasn't
scary enough or funny enough to stand on
its own Bride of Chucky is rotten at 47
on the Tomato Meter with 38 reviews and
it has a 47 audience score so what did
the critics have to say in Iran review
Lawrence van gelder of the New York
times wrote the novelty of a bloody
horror film built around a malevolent
doll carrying the soul of a serial
killer has worn thin however in a fresh
review Antonia Quirk of the UK's
independent on Sunday wrote Bride of
Chucky is easily the best of the four
film Chucky franchise and it's a barmy
witty horror movie full of scream-like
ironies the Rotten Tomatoes critics
consensus reads Bride of Chucky is
devoid of any fright and the franchise
has become tiresomely self-periodic
although horror fans might find some
pleasure in this fourth entries Camp
Factor so that's Bride of Chucky let's
kick it back to Jacqueline and Mark your
friends till the end back to you folks
and you are my buddy remember the the
female version of my buddy was big
sister Kid Sister Kid Sister oh so
creepy and my buddy kid's sister
arguably even creepier that I don't know
it's hard to get creepier than my buddy
I would stick with a Teddy Ruxpin and
even that you can make pretty dark if
you put a Black Sabbath tape in instead
of the tape that Teddy Ruxpin was
supposed to be playing you can have fun
with that at home right now we're gonna
transition into movie talk
[Music]
foreign I love hearing the stories of
when people Saw movies for the first
time and for some reason I love the
horror movies the most when we have
these kind of conversations because I
got to see this last night turn all the
lights off me and the dog popped a big
thing of popcorn loved me some Bride of
Chucky Jacqueline you saw it a few years
ago most recently I guess like recently
issues when I first I think saw it
obviously I knew what the it's not a
movie that hides its plot let's be very
clear here I knew what I was getting
into but yeah it was after that I think
I just like you know popped in some
Voodoo codes that you know we get here
or Fandango codes and I was like oh let
me like watch this one and I watched it
pretty quickly uh but the first Chucky I
saw I saw my cable
I didn't see it in the theaters
obviously I was way too young
um but when I did finally see it was on
cable and even on cable I was like this
should not be on TV this is disturbing
that's why you're the best part of this
show I I kind of tread water and you're
the star because you bring up even
better points like that so Dorena before
I ask you when you stop right at Chucky
what was your first experience with the
child's play franchise yeah well as uh
Mark knows I grew up in Mexico and uh in
Mexico the difference is that you
actually get to see movies in network TV
that are not meant for Network TV in
America and so uh Child's Play played
during the day
dubbed in Spanish right so I saw that as
a kid and I was the weird messed up kid
that I was I wanted to keep watching it
even though that I was super scared and
my grandma's like what are you watching
I'm like it's just just a movie about
dolls yeah it's fine it is a good movie
to kind of pull the wool over the
parents eyes because they don't really
know they just see like a toy and it's
like yeah I know it's a kids movie don't
worry about it yeah do you think parents
pay attention if they don't have other
siblings ratting on them because like
you grew up with siblings like for me my
parents didn't know what I was watching
because they would have to be sitting
there watching it with me to know where
is it I feel like it's only when you
have siblings do they say you shouldn't
be watching this I just spent the last
two weeks with my sister and her family
my brother and his family parents don't
know anything they don't they're not
paying attention to anything these kids
that's what I'm saying like it's not
because they're bad parents because
they're so tired they don't sleep no
they don't sleep they're just barely
trying to figure out what to have for
dinner tonight they have no idea you're
all superheroes that was just I mean I
just wanted to say like legitimately
you're like I was thinking about it's
like I should not have been watching
this you probably you know your grandma
should be watching this did anybody know
I feel like the thing with Child's Play
and I I can't recall like sitting down
and watching Child's Play start to
finish I'm sure my sister and I caught
it on USA up all night hosted by the
lake great Gilbert he's like playing
mini golf with three models yeah
um I think I probably caught it there
somewhere but I feel like Chucky was the
more I don't know uh digestible sort of
horror movie villain if you're a parent
you're like I think I'd rather have them
watch a child's play than a Freddy
Krueger or a Hellraiser or a Hellraiser
a Jason a Michael Myers that kind of
thing even though the the kids
imagination can take the Chucky thing
and run with it because you have stuff
in your room that probably looks like
Chucky or resembles the chuckiness of it
but if you look at Bride of Chucky
I came across that as an adult and so
like I'm ready to have fun with this and
I think that this movie coming out in
1998 which is a decade after the first
Child's Play I think that every kid like
you dorina who saw Chucky when you were
probably too young to meet Chuck and you
probably all of us then were adults now
and we kind of have a sense of humor
about this movies like scream certainly
helped we see Bride of Chucky I think it
came along at the exact right time did
you see this in the theaters yes did you
um also I was actually in high school
still in Mexico and so I saw La Novia de
Chucky uh that's what it was titled down
there and I was about 16. so I was the
perfect age to receive the campy horror
because I was such a huge fan of the
scream franchise and uh obvious I do
want to say a shout out uh I know Team
America is a masterpiece yeah uh but
that was not the first puppet sex scene
no no yeah it was very bright of Chucky
that I and I think well
it was not the fur there was also
animated sex scenes that had come out
before then there's some animators and
stop animation sex scenes that have come
out before then but there had not been
puppets and watching the puppets get it
on and how they're making light of it
like again this movie is funny
throughout there's a comedic thread that
does not stop I about stood up and
scared the dog I was so excited to see
John Ritter's name yeah yeah because
John Ritter an all-time great sitcom
actor and he's just so great with
physical comedy he doesn't get to do a
lot of that here because he's the bad
chief of police who's trying to keep
Katherine Heigl's character Jade from
being with this other dude uh played by
Nick stabile I think and um it's like
okay so they have that Jade and Jesse
are the two characters who are sort of
looking to escape town but then you also
have Chucky and his now bride who has
become his bride because they kind of
pulled those footage on each other and
now they're both stuck in puppets
they're both two couples fighting yeah
there what did they call it two couples
at War what do they call that it's it's
a heartbreaking thing in this movie
Dorena because you really feel like in a
different world uh Chucky and and his
betrothed could really hang out with
Jesse and Jade and like go on a nice
double date and really get along pretty
well yeah but that's not what happens in
the Chucky franchise no it tends to go
bad pretty quick what's one of your
favorite standout scenes of this movie
is it the is it the you know is it the
puppet sex um you know that's a great
one uh but no the ending is one of my
favorite scenes in a horror movie ever
because it's so ridiculous and
surprising and I don't think you see it
coming uh we can talk about it
out there for the end of Bride of Chucky
where we think that we finally have
Chucky's underground and we got him
taken care of the Bride has just been
burned to a crisp there's no way that
she's getting out of this but then
something happens with Tiffany where she
starts screaming and I think oh she's
coming back to life it's a lot more than
that yes uh life found a way
into uh the puppet vagina and a little
Seed of Chucky came out it's amazing and
it's you know it's a little puppet fetus
covered in blood with teeth that's about
to attack the cop it's amazing and
that's how it ends and that's how it is
and it sets up the sequel which was of
course the I was literally I was like
what do you mean I was like oh the
sequel set up I thought I was like what
did I miss and I was like yeah Seed of
Chucky which I just checked is 34 I
think on Rotten Tomatoes so it kept
getting worse but you know what's funny
Bride of Chucky is I think only the
fifth highest rated Child's Play movie
the TV show is like 91 yes the TV show
does really well yeah but both the
child's play is the one where Mark
Hamill provided the voice that came out
a couple years ago and then the original
1988 those are both fresh I think
Charles played two is fresh and so
there's a lot of freshness with this
friend a Curse of Chucky I think might
be the highest rated
Child's Play movie on the tomatoes wow
Curse of Chucky is 75 look at that fresh
from 2013. Cult of Chucky is 78 fresh a
lot of freshness hey there's this movie
Hey listen I am not gonna doubt the
power of Chucky it's good it gets better
Innings than leprechaun and I defend the
leprechaun franchise a ton I really do
thank you verses again for showing your
knowledge on this subject uh I really do
appreciate it that's real thanks to our
expert researcher Mark
take most of the credit for verses I
just wanted to add two with Bride of
Chucky that it came out in 1998 this was
a movie of the MTV generation I think
people need to like also remember this I
remember this all over the MTV Movie
Awards I remember this being like
definitely a movie that you saw in TRL
you saw you definitely it felt again
like your point people that maybe saw it
when they were seven or eight they were
18 20 definitely a part of that
generation watching it now as a as a
movie I think that definitely like they
picked the right time to come back
completely yeah that metal sort of goth
marriage where you have like you could
see Marilyn Manson This popularity On
The Rise just watching this movie but I
also think that the genius about this
movie is that if it took itself more
seriously we would be asking ourselves a
lot of questions like so wait is there
are there blood and guts and
reproductive organs inside these puppets
because there's a scene where Chucky
gets stabbed and then he's bleeding out
the back and it's like but you're a
you're a toy so how does this but it the
movie doesn't care to answer those
questions it's just taking us for a ride
and the movie knows what it is and I
like when art is confident enough to be
like this is what I am I don't care
about what I'm not I'm just gonna have
fun with this and it sets up our human
character so well in one of my favorite
scenes where we're going to the dance
and it's the the beginning of the movie
in this nice nice kid shows up to take
Catherine Heigl's character Jade to some
dance and you gotta go through the dad
or in this case the uncle who is John
Ritter who happens to be the chief of
police okay they don't get along uh John
Ritter and Catherine Heil don't get
along they have a weird relationship so
he thinks that oh this guy's taking her
out but he no he's the chief of police
he's wiser than this he knows that this
is just the friend who is not interested
because he's gay and so Catherine Heigl
actually is going to the dance with
Jesse the chief of police pulls them
over and is like I caution the act and
so we instantly know John Ritter's gonna
get his comeuppance and we don't know
what's going to happen with this couple
but they're gonna probably make a run
for it and Jennifer Tilly's character
Tiffany gives them the perfect reason to
do so because we gotta get this amulet
so that we can get these two I just love
explaining this movie I feel like I'm
explaining this movie to like my mom or
something and she's already like checked
out but this is just what the Ride the
movie takes you on and it's really
really hard I don't tell the movie
because it's like okay we gotta put this
person's body in this party because
they're trying to get away by infusing
their souls into the puppets because
they're like we'll live forever it's the
worst thing in the world but it's the
best thing in the world this is the
worst thing in the world to explain yes
it is the best thing in the world though
because how else do you explain later
the massive RV fight with the oven
between those two which is my favorite
scene because I'm glad you set all that
up because literally I was like okay I
gotta set up why these people are this
way and you did it perfectly so now I
don't have to but the RV fight is like
so good first of all put the doll in the
oven brilliant well it's it's one of the
things where like that was one of the
first fights where they actually treated
the dolls like dolls in the sense of how
they went about them and then the dolls
also acted like Yoda in the prequel as
far as like how they went back at them
like it felt like a very like Am I Wrong
watching it it is a very physics in the
sense of like this is what somebody
would do with a little doll attacking
yeah
I mean like just throw it in the oven
you're not gonna pretend like this is a
formidable thing it's almost laughable
so it's just like when you would have
like an angry like wild kid trying to
attack you put it in a small box put it
on a shelf I loved that about this is it
really treated them like the tiny
inanimate objects it was even though
they could kill them yeah and I loved
that fight very physical very funny but
and give it up for the puppeteers that
those were puppets that was not CGI with
those moves they were literally throwing
these dolls yeah they had about I think
like seven people uh managing each of
the puppets it was incredible with the
visual effects artists too like they
really treated it like a visual effect
shoot in the sense like this would have
been just like as if they didn't have
anything that was going to be really
scoped over yeah and I love that you
brought up that scene because it really
when everything comes together and you
really hear Brad duraf and Jennifer
Tilly having a blast during the scene
because that's when they actually this
is after they have the puppet sex and
they make love or whatever and and then
she gets really mad at him right and and
she she does that whole monologue where
she's like Arthur Stewart and then she
ends with ticket from me honey plastic
is no substitute for a nice hunk of wood
it's so good yeah
take turns and I thought that was a
genius move by the creators of this is
that you have these now these two dolls
and you could very easily just have them
both be these you know malignant
entities that are just possessed and are
just evil and they are they have that
evil bent they're both very obsessed
with serial killing but they have
distinct personalities and they're
different from one another and that adds
a spice to it and so the scene you're
talking about the leads up to it is
where we have the two got so we have
Chucky who's kind of got a gun on Jesse
and then we have Tiffany who's got a
knife to or whatever to Jade and they're
both sort of taking hostages but they're
also kind of just we need to do some
girl talk we need to do some boy talk
and it ends up kind of turning into a
fight to the relationship yeah and the
the toss in the oven is amazing because
it's an homage sort of the Gremlins
where you throw a gremlin into the
microwave there's also another great
Star Wars reference in this which one
it's where Chucky is just look
he's a fun guy for a night ladies yeah
okay he's not a long-term boyfriend
because he's obsessed with himself and
so when Tiffany tells him I love you he
says I know and it's like the most evil
demented Han Solo
before he goes into the uh you know the
ice chamber
I love you Chucky
I know
We Belong Together Forever
oh my god I didn't even think about that
because the way he says it it doesn't
hit the same way
I'm literally like oh my God that is a
Star Wars reference and it's funny that
I mentioned it at that time because I'm
just putting it in a different
unintentional stuff but the literal
fights I do think are great when they
show these full body humans really
fighting these dolls the only time I've
ever really seen that done outside of
the force awakens I'm sorry the the
um uh attack of the Clones yeah the
first prequel only the thing I will add
to I love that even in 1998 we establish
that women are fed up with toxic
masculinity yeah like even in this movie
even though it was written and directed
by men and clearly there had been some
women that women that punched up this
script because the anger the exhaustion
and the frustration that Jennifer Tilly
is talking about as a doll in this movie
is the same thing that litters my fyp
page of like these Housewives who have
husbands that like won't empty the
dishwasher sure like I don't understand
it I grew up in a house like that and my
house is completely different than that
in fact I am the incompetent husband
like I'm the one yeah
exactly no I mean but like literally I'm
the person that's like let's just get a
maid like I don't want to do this but
this is the same thing inequal an
inequality him focusing on his dreams
and not really taking care this is like
real couple stuff that they're actually
talking about in this absurdist manner
but that's why it hits and it's so cool
that this is the fourth entry into the
franchise and that it's completely
different than anything we've seen
before right that's what's so great
about uh don Mancini and what he's so
beloved by us horror nerds that you know
he started this franchise uh with a
completely unique idea of like the doll
my buddy coming into life and then he
continued it but he's like you know what
I think Chucky needs a girlfriend and uh
because that's that's what happens in
life like he actually gave this little
toy a storyline yeah to continue and
even have kids and he showed how toxic
that would probably be given all of the
things that this person did before then
or maybe he hired a writer that could
realize like hey on his first murder
Rampage we can't make this just hugs and
kisses this needs to be a struggle it
really is like a relationship that
you're trying to form into something
meaningful because everybody longs to be
with somebody right yeah and so and and
you have interests and you know I enjoy
sports and I enjoy uh sleeping those are
my interests I like dogs too so I'm
pretty easy to please with with Tiffany
and with Chucky Charles Lee Ray the
serial killer who died and then his
Spirit possessed the doll of Chucky they
both love killing they're so obsessed
with it to the point where even their
friends around them are like hey I'm not
ready to kill yet I'm like I'm into this
God stuff I'm not ready to be a mass
murderer they found each other and God
bless Tiffany for trying to make it work
but you just can't you can't get through
to Charles Libre you can't do it not at
first
like every good rom-com there's the
gonna be the grand declaration and this
Grand declaration is pretty up there
when he finally does say you know I want
to be with you and propose that is like
yeah like that is Lift Me Up Where We
Belong that is Richard Gere
I mean I think yeah I think it's when um
uh When Tiffany actually kills the
couple yes right and like throws the
bottle at the ceiling mirror and then
all of these uh shards of glass kill the
couple and then Chucky gets so impressed
he's like I love you and that's when
they started yes yes
but it's amazing how many kills in this
movie there are some fun kills I thought
the the chief of police played by John
Ritter kill was pretty fun because you
get it sort of twice and because he just
gets a face full of nails
so he just just gets tossed into this
sort of trunk of the back of the RV but
then he comes back because he's the
chief of police damn it and he's John
Ritter and we booked John Ritter for
this we're gonna give him one more Scene
I mean of course you have to also this
is such a movie that's like a horror
head it's not even an Easter egg it's
more of like this is just for you that's
just for them that Pinhead thing is just
for the Horizon and the Bride of
Frankenstein stuff yeah it's another one
of my favorite scenes is where Chucky
ends up murdering Jennifer Tilly's human
version of Tiffany yeah because she's in
the bath she's enjoying she's having
champagne she's wearing she's crying to
Bride of Frankenstein actually yeah yeah
yeah and she's watching brother
Frankenstein we're seeing that it just
so clearly communicated and not in a way
that it's ripping off Bride of
Frankenstein it's paying homage but it's
also updating it for this generation and
I thought it was really well done as I
talk about this movie I'm sort of more
impressed with the the comedic Genius of
it it's a very it's a very dark take but
it's really really funny stuff and I
think the reason why we're glossing over
it's a very broad comedy every single
one of the laughs these are like right
up there with like Ace Ventura Dumb and
Dumber type you know really broad
laughter and I think maybe at the time
and I'm not saying this is what Tim said
or whatever I think critics just can't
think that there's a great really
incredible movie which is surprising
because you know who he borrows this
kind of stuff from like Preston Sturgis
Charlie Chaplin that's really what this
is is these are like really like old
school Vaudeville techniques literally
that they're using to now really sort of
tell this different story but underneath
all of that bro if you took out the
sight gags off of it it's a pretty good
emotional character Arc underneath here
there really is and and if you look at
you know the is this the best in the
series I can't really speak that I
haven't seen every movie in this
definitely not but I will say it was a
huge step forward for representation
because this is back again in 98 and you
have an lgbtq bent like years before
this was sort of in mainstream media at
all I mean you have Alexis Arquette is
in the movie definitely just a lot of a
lot of overtones and a lot of Shades and
David the character is also queer yeah
and there's and nobody asked anything
like Catherine Heigl's character just
talks to him about it like it's normal
right because it should be and so it
definitely is nice so this was back when
they just passed don't ask don't tell
you couldn't literally talk about that
stuff in the military so it's like when
you look at it now it looks like oh of
course but at the time very Progressive
but it was also horror a place where you
you can be very Progressive and I I
think that the movie that's coming up
that we're also you know sort of getting
geared up to go enjoy in theaters
because these are the fun horror movies
to go see in a theater like I've always
said horror movies and comedies two best
opening weekends to see at a movie
theater because the audience is either
laughing together or scared or in the
case of a Bride of Chucky probably both
yeah you get some cool kills you get a
lot of laughs I think Megan is gonna be
sort of in that mold where you have some
comedic moments because it's just so
absurd but you also have some some
actual scares in it during a you've seen
Megan
what do you think as far as holding up
to the lineage of a Bride of Chucky you
know it reminded me I'm a huge fan of
Aquila Cooper's um malignant I think it
was one of one of the funniest horror
movies to come out recently and uh and
so I was I had high hopes for Megan and
it's still it's not as funny as
malignant but it had some incredible
moments that I think really
um paid homage to Child's Play and um it
and also kind of actually the the reboot
with Mark Hamill uh that came out a
couple of years ago that focused more on
the HAL 9000 like AI version of it yeah
and so there's so much that writers can
play with that and so uh it was it was I
think a lot of people are going to love
uh Megan the character and it's going to
become not as maybe not as iconic as
Chucky but I think you're going to see a
lot of people dressed up as her for
Halloween I think uh the everybody from
uh girls to the LGBT community is going
to want to be Megan and is going to want
to be friends with her and I just
thought was a lot of fun and Allison
Williams is great in it she plays this
super uh you know Crazy Character
because she's an engineer that's
building you know yeah this creepy doll
that's basically going to turn into you
know a murderer exactly she's going to
go into murderers so it's it's I thought
it was really great I I had a lot of fun
and I recommend people go see it
especially if you're a fan of Chucky did
you all see uh the the Rams and Chargers
played a couple weeks ago yeah so if I
say the halftime show part of a halftime
show was a bunch of Megan's at the
50-yard line all doing like a weird
creepy dance it was awesome the creepy
um it was so cool marketing like I think
smile reminded us of something that used
to be like they used to do a lot which
was guerrilla marketing and I think
between those two between both smile and
has people show it up like at random
sporting events and they're just smiling
into the camera and those are like paid
actors yeah and this one yeah they did
that and then Jason Blum he dressed up
as Megan yeah they're like Christmas
party well you saw the film which is
great I was supposed to go see it last
night sorry blumhouse if you're watching
this now I was tired I didn't make it
last night but I'm gonna see you this
weekend like but I was just about to say
to you mark you did the junket for it
it's not just a pretty face ladies and
gentlemen he does know how to ask the
question so um tell us all about uh your
your time with the cast of Megan sir
okay and did you get to interview Megan
God I feel like I'm on NPR now this is
so fun I did not get to talk to Megan
but when I talked to James Juan and
Jason Blum it was so fun because if
something drain it kind of hit on is
with even with Bride of Chucky that's
more Supernatural invading the dolls
right it goes back to stuff like the
Exorcist where okay this is some sort of
paranormal thing that's happening and
now this Spirit has invaded this doll
yeah but Megan is replacing the
supernatural aspect of it with a sort of
technological devil yeah and that is
that's arguably scary carrier as a
concept because that's where the world
is going it's like we were back in this
like spiritual realm you know where we
thought all the stars were gods or
whatever and now we're starting to move
into where we worship technology so that
gets into the doll and that's I think I
was terrified of The Exorcist okay
because possession is something you
can't really prepare for yes you know
you can't necessarily like go to the gym
and get rid of the devil and same thing
with that kind of exercise Invasion of
the Body Snatchers any of those sort of
like take your essence and and exist
without you sort of things it really
cuts to the quick of what humanity is
because that's all we have is
consciousness uh I just want to say too
with uh Megan I hope it does very very
well because it's also a movie that I
think he's in on this whole idea of uh
you know smart people coming together to
make good stuff the fact that James won
and Jason blonde now have a partnership
after his many years at Warner Brothers
if this movie ends up being successful
this weekend I think it's just more
evidence of like Hollywood is a
relationship business and I don't think
anybody awarded person is going to be
happy to see their literal Golden Boy
think about how many movies that they've
had success of in recent years between
Sinister Insidious none all of that
stuff and in addition to that also the
Aquaman series like this dude is like
there should be wings at WB built off
for him and now he's partnered up with
universal and that is this is that first
time totally Jacqueline and I'm so
thankful for Aquaman making billions
because that's how we got malignant that
is how we got malignant that's how we
got all of this and this is the crazy we
got all of those movies that were under
their banner and now they're going
elsewhere it's gonna be very interesting
going forward think about how big of a
success to your point malignant was yeah
and they could bake both of those kind
of movies on the cheap where they cost
maybe five ten million dollars 15
million dollars to make and apparently
according to my experience half of that
budget goes to the delicious snacks and
craft Services because they are second
to none here and I'm not allowed to
touch them I've been reprimanded
multiple times uh and I do want to give
it one more shout out to Aquila Cooper
who wrote the uh Megan and and malignant
and she's just a delight to talk to her
he had to meet her comic I think we're
all probably yep surge waiting at the
same party and just awesome to talk to
really down to earth and a genius when
it comes to this stuff okay fun fact
here as far as the I didn't realize that
chunky kind of did this well the chunky
movies did this well at the box office
but if you look at Bride of Chucky 73
million dollars worldwide that's off of
a budget of 25 million dollars so we
adjusted those numbers for inflation but
that's pretty impressive stuff Child's
Play came out and was caught cost 10
million dollars this is the most recent
one in 2019 and ended up pulling in 44
million dollars but the original Child's
Play worldwide adjusted for inflation 83
million dollars that is still the
breadwinner off a budget of just nine
million bucks so those Child's Play
movies do we want to keep them coming to
Arena I'm never gonna be sick of China
look if they keep making if they keep
bringing back Michael Myers they can
keep bringing back very fast this is
very true and they they have then so
many times so many times I just have
other people I'd like I I do another
Leprechaun movie I was gonna ask what's
the what's the horror movie villain that
y'all are like okay we brought back
Michael Myers Chucky's sort of continues
to get a TV show or a movie greenlit
who's the horror movie villain do you
think has been shortchanged that we need
to get back in the Limelight I was
pretty you missed Freddy yeah I don't I
he's my favorite I think he is my
favorite I just think the people that
would make it good or not available
anymore and so I don't want to see it
made badly you know what I mean like
legit like you know totally but at least
one last Robert Englund yes you can
maybe get one last Robert England out of
it um for me like I don't think we need
more leprechauns but the leprechaun is
the gift that keeps on giving that is my
personal opinion like without question
that that franchise um there are no late
Innings there are no late endings with
that franchise it's all a win it's like
jackass it's like jackass if if you show
me a moment when a murderous leprechaun
is not funny I will show you a moment
when we don't need to make another
leprechaun con movie just like if you
show me a moment where a guy getting
kicked in the nuts is not funny I will
tell you we don't need another jackass
but as long as those things are true
yeah well it's like going back to your
uh Vaudeville point right like it's
never not funny to see Chucky being
kicked yes just like the gremlin in the
microwave yeah it's it's just there's
certain I mean whatever the comedy
purists over here may disagree with me I
just think there's some unshakable
tenements of what will make people laugh
and a murderous leprechaun is one of
them yes I will tell you not as the Best
comedian in the world but I will tell
you as a comedian in the world
um puppets in the oven always works
always good for a laugh puppets fighting
each other in a grave yes always good
for yucks yeah and the end of this movie
as darina so eloquently pointed out when
we do give birth to a new thing reminded
me of the movie it's alive oh yeah you
remember that it's like this killer baby
that's attacking people in the very end
of the first it's alive it's like
finally we got this baby and we ended
this this demon baby and the chief gets
a call he's probably not played by John
Saxon but in my head he is played by
John Saxon he gets a call that oh no
they discovered another one like up in
Seattle or something there's another
it's a live baby I remember the it's the
live movie I don't remember the Beats of
it's here details also I just remembered
one horror sex comedies oh yeah we need
more horror sex comedies that I don't
know who the villain of that is other
than virginity so I guess that is the
next Monster I would like to see
Conquest that's a good point because
we've gotten horror more uh sex drama
it's kind of like it follows right that
was basically yeah that was not funny
dude the fact that this guy was paranoid
about getting herpes and let that
fantasy rain out it's just the most
hilarious thing in the world we're
talking about how much we want horror
sex comedies and what do teenagers like
to do when they go camping they like to
have sex and who likes to murder kids
when they're camping Jason Jason
Voorhees that's true that's all I'm
saying maybe it's time for Jason
Voorhees to get some run so that is
going to do it for movie talk here today
with not just Bride of Chucky we got
into some leprechaun we got into some
Megan which is in theaters now a lot of
fun stuff here and we also have time for
mailbag so Brian hit the music
[Music]
Clayton Chavez is our big winner here
today fresh member of the ketchup crew
thank you Clayton and everybody for
enjoying this show on a weekly basis
Clayton writes dear Mark and Jacqueline
I don't know why I haven't submitted
this yet and I hope others have before
me
1999's mystery men's rating is far too
low at 61 percent let alone its audience
score 57 it breaks my heart this film is
underrated and deserves to be talked
about stack cast hilarious quick-witted
and it proves that 90 superhero films
can work Mystery Men people come on
death man is dead this is some serious
Doctor Strange Love War Room writing
here keep making amazing episodes thank
you Clayton for that Mystery Men we have
thoughts I've is this the Donald is this
the Donald Glover one Ben Stiller Ben
Stiller David and David Duchovny
from uh Keenan and Kel right I believe I
believe so yeah and cook we're getting
the yes from uh from Brian James Quick
Pops in there I I will take a look at
this the one I would wanted
the one I always get it confused with
and the one I would rather go with is uh
the watch because there's two random
you know Ben Stiller movies that like
feel like songs in a different key and
it's the watch and Mystery Men you're
going with a watch over mystery then
okay because they're team-ups you know
trying to fight things and they're all
like a ragtag group basically like
that's the so in my brain those two
movies like are just you know Ben
Stiller's the lead and they he's got to
cast the jokes around him trying to do
something yeah I always felt like
history men to me looked like and again
never seen the movie but it looked like
sort of the last hurray for like a 90s
sort of superhero movie before we had to
take it oh so seriously that we got the
Spider-Man trilogy a couple years later
X-Men blade all in the Forefront leading
into the MCU so this was the last you
know Bastion of hey remember the Reality
Bites guy yeah I'm gonna make a
superhero movie just have some fun with
it so yeah maybe Mystery Men should be
on this show sooner rather than later uh
astrud darina returning to the show
because you're always great in person in
studio virtual doesn't matter we love
having you working all the kids out
there find you thank you for having me
uh we are I am as Mark said earlier I am
one a third of the world girls and we
literally give things a whirl so if
you're into jackass or the try guys or a
sexier version of Mr Rogers uh catches
everywhere on the YouTubes on the social
media uh we got a podcast called
out of water uh we are basically trying
to conquer the world by uh creating
fewer in cells I like that I think
that's a nice sexier version Mr Rogers
is a good tagline there but it shows
some skin I mean maybe not some skin but
he took some clothes off on the show he
did he did he didn't have a counter like
the world nobody mentions the fact that
every day just like RuPaul Mr Rogers had
to get into drag to do the performance
it's a good point nobody talks about
that that was a drag sweater
he was put legitimately he was Jim
Rogers walking in the door he was Mr
Rogers with that girl that is drag that
is a heightened Performance Based on
what you appear to be wow okay all right
I'm with Jack
so check out the World Girls uh
Jacqueline by the way and I'll close out
the show by saying this I love that
you're in the thick of award season yeah
and I love seeing her on social media
stump for your favorite movie of last
year jackass forever never stop never
stopping and I will say all of my you
know
I would say like less like-minded
critics are very much letting me know
really of all the city like it's kind of
a a shot in the face of somebody like
you know in in your D2 who spent 10
years working on Bardo that I'm like
yeah that's cute give me the dudes with
the nuts hey literally the best opening
scene in a movie last year
seriously incredible yeah it was a great
theatrical experience yeah and uh we're
talking about fine Cinema on this show
we're talking about Bride of Chucky
we're talking about jackass forever and
we're talking about a good one next week
too well actually I should say I don't
want to steal Mark's Thunder uh I want
to say again thank you so much for being
here Dorian did we get you a
recommendation though no oh yeah give us
give us a quick recommendation and then
we'll we'll sign out I believe last time
I was here I recommended Barbarian which
was my favorite movie of last year I
made my top 10 off incredible uh so uh I
will recommend uh older movie from like
2018 which is one of my favorite horror
movies that's very underrated by Panos
cosmato starring Nicholas Cage and that
is called Mandy I recommend it all the
time it's so underrated it looks uh it's
a psychedelic trip it looks beautiful
and it's a hilarious uh it's a very sad
and hilarious 80s uh kind of horror
Revenge movie amazing stuff also a great
for a rainy day so I appreciate you
giving that since it's raining right
here thank you again Andrea I want to
say next week we've uh we got Angels
Fallen yes I was gonna say because this
is the man who I forgive much and that
is Gerard Butler not because of 300
either I just like gosh I'm so excited
yeah we're doing Angela's Fallen but I
just liked Gerard Butler I'm somebody
that like will defend geostorm and uh
you know all of the things that he does
he was very hot as a Phantom of the
Opera that's the reason why that is the
reason why he has my Everlasting
affection is not for 300. it's for
Phantom he's a hot Phantom of the Opera
I love him as like the down and out kind
of cop that just gritty and breaking the
rules um I will say geostorm is great
for one reason and one reason only and
you all get to hear that next week on
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong can we talk
about angel has fallen for Doreen Ariano
check out the World Girls wherever you
do whirly things check out Jaclyn Coley
and myself on social media thank you
everybody for watching Rotten Tomatoes
is wrong go to RT which is
rottentomatoes.com and you can check out
our list like the child's player ranking
all the Blum House movies ranked there's
a lot of fun horror movie stuff on there
it's still raining it's probably raining
where you are so enjoy a horror movie
and a couple episodes of Rotten Tomatoes
is wrong for Jacqueline Dorena Brian
Glenn myself I Mark Ellis wish you a Jew
[Music]
thank you